veamos si podemos encontrar cuánto es x
+ 3 por x menos 3 y te recomiendo que le
pongas una pausa el vídeo y lo intentes
por tu cuenta
bueno una forma de atacar este problema
es atacarlo de la misma forma que
siempre podemos atacar a la
multiplicación de dos binomios o sea
aplicar la propiedad distributiva dos
veces así es que podemos tomar este x +
3 amarillo entero y multiplicarlo por
cada uno de estos términos podemos
multiplicar lo primero por esta x y nos
queda x por x + 3 y después lo vamos a
multiplicar por menos 3 y nos queda
menos 3
por x + 3 y ahora volvemos a aplicar la
propiedad distributiva y entonces
tomamos esta x y la distribuimos a lo
largo de este x + 3 y x x x es x al
cuadrado y x x 3 es 3x y ahora lo
hacemos de este lado menos 3 x x es
menos 3x y menos 3 x 3 es menos 9 y
ahora este polinomio en que se
simplifica pues nos queda x al cuadrado
3 x menos 3 x se cancela y nos queda
simplemente x al cuadrado menos 9
y listo ahora aquí también podemos
encontrar un patrón muy interesante por
aquí tenemos esta x y la multiplicamos
por esta x y nos queda x al cuadrado y
luego si tomamos 3 y lo multiplicamos
por menos 3 nos queda menos 9 y estos
términos de enmedio se cancelaron ahora
una pregunta muy interesante es si esto
sucede siempre porque si estamos
haciendo una multiplicación de binomios
y sumamos un número y luego lo restamos
nos quedará siempre algo de este estilo
bueno pues lo podemos intentar podemos
hablar en términos más generales si aquí
en lugar de poner x más 3 x x menos 3
ponemos algo de este estilo como x +
por equis menos a bueno aquí otra vez te
recomiendo que le pongas una pausa el
vídeo y trabajes con esto que tenemos
aquí supón que está a puede ser
cualquier número puede ser un 3 o algún
otro número aplica la propiedad
distributiva dos veces y observa qué es
lo que queda bueno ahora vamos a
trabajar con esto juntos primero tomamos
el x más a amarillo y lo distribuimos en
el x menos a y entonces tenemos x más a
x x que es lo mismo que x x x + a y
luego vamos a tener menos a por x más a
menos
x + a y observa lo único que hice fue
distribuir todo este pedazo todo este x
+ adjunto en el x y en el menos a porque
lo estoy multiplicando por x y lo estoy
multiplicando por menos a y ahora
podemos aplicar la propiedad
distributiva otra vez ok
x x x es x al cuadrado y x x a
a x y por acá menos a por x es menos a x
y menos a por a
es menos al cuadrado y observa aquí
tenemos a x menos a equis y estos dos
términos se van a cancelar así es que
por aquí no es que sólo haya funcionado
porque teníamos un 3 para cualquier
número y nos va a quedar a x menos a
equis y eso se va a cancelar y nos va a
quedar únicamente x al cuadrado menos a
al cuadrado ok menos a al cuadrado y
aquí podemos ver casos especiales aunque
sí tenemos x más alguna cosa por x menos
esa alguna cosa lo que nos va a quedar
es x al cuadrado menos esa cosa al
cuadrado ok y esto de aquí es muy
importante saberlo es muy útil y nos
sirve para calcular muy rápido
multiplicaciones que sigan este patrón
no querer por ejemplo si yo llegara y te
dijera rápido rápido cuánto es
x + 10 por x menos 10 tú podrías llegar
y decir oye esto si sigue este mismo
patrón porque tenemos x + a por x menos
a y entonces sabemos inmediatamente que
esto es igual a x al cuadrado menos a al
cuadrado pero si bien es igual a a a al
cuadrado tiene que ser 100 así es que
puedes hacer muy rápido esta
multiplicación una vez que reconoces el
patrón